we welcome andrew brandt here to the
rich eisen show susie schuster in for
rich eisen and
andrew we saw a very transparent
aaron rodgers in front of the media in
green bay
what do you make of what you've seen
unfolding so far there
well susie i've sort of followed this a
long time and i was not surprised by any
of it
including aaron being on the presser
yesterday
and being candid thoughtful honest
professional
and laying it out you know this is not a
guy that's going to give you a lot of bs
answers give you the cliches that a lot
of athletes and coaches do
so i was not surprised and what i make
of it is what i've made of it all along
you know there was an expiration date
put on aaron rodgers and the packers
in april of 2020 when they took a first
round quarterback as we did 15 years ago
and i always thought that expiration
date and still do
is 2022. and i think it's becoming clear
that's the case they want aaron rodgers
to give them mvp play
for one more year while keeping the seat
warm
for the next guy and aaron's not down
with it but he understands
he doesn't have many options and he
talked about it
so it's going to be a professional
relationship
kind of a coexisting for the next four
or five months
and they're going to part ways i've said
it all along
you have to wonder about the experience
he had when brett favre was there and he
came in
and how that impacted how he's going
forward not only with the team but with
his
future replacement what do you think
that experience
that he went through when brett favre
was not all that warm and not all that
uh encompassing
how did that affect him mentally and how
is that playing out in front of our eyes
right now
yeah i mean which you know there's a few
differences but obviously a lot of
parallels and i felt a lot of deja vu
the past year because you know
they traded up to get jordan you know
aaron kind of fell in our lap we didn't
expect to take a quarterback
it was an amazing moment where this guy
just slid all the way down
to our pick of 24 the packers went up
and got
jordan love and having been in
management so long
i get it you know people out there
wonder you know the worst time to get a
quarterback is when you really need a
quarterback
so the packers are always prepared but
they have to manage it
right so in my day we had to manage that
you know brett's camp is always saying
this is no fun
coming into work and sitting next to
your replacement every day
and aaron's camp was saying am i ever
going to play
are they ever going to play and i think
from the aaron side he was a good
soldier most of the year but it bugged
them
and i think as he said yesterday susie
this is a lot more than
jordan love i mean it just feels like
he doesn't get received well
his input and that's okay you know play
teams don't really go to players for
personnel input
but i think it's just more a sense of i
don't think he feels anyone in the front
office
is his point person like like he can sit
down and talk about things beyond
football like there's a trust
i just think like he's like you know in
so many words saying these guys don't
care about me
and we'll just do this for the next six
months and i'll be i'll be somewhere
else
so then it seems almost confusing then
because we
all thought in the media that they had
made concessions brian go to goodston
and the the organization in green bay
to include him more and then we heard
from the gm
well i'm the one making the decisions
but we do have to take his input more
obviously the randall cobb trade shows
that they were listening to him
where do you see this co-existing and do
you think really they
will listen to him more why wouldn't
they when you've got a quarterback going
into a 17th season with the organization
who's proven so it's funny like you'd
think especially in the way
things have changed with the nfl and
quarterbacks now with these older
quarterbacks like tom brady
where do you see this actually playing
out and leveling
out in terms of his input
you know i i don't think there's going
to be much of that i really don't
i just think you know what was
telling this offseason is the reporting
of
the coach the general manager and the
president all going out to la to see
aaron
yet here we are i mean i think the
message they got
aaron got was listen we manage you play
and i still think that and even the
presser this morning
were good at [ __ ] basically said yeah
we went and got randall cobb for
and we wouldn't have done that without
him it was kind of like a feeling like
okay we're done you know it's kind of
like yeah
okay we did that and i just you know
in my day ted thompson he was not a he
was an elite talent evaluator but he was
not a communicator
and he relied on me and john schneider
and john dorsey and reggie mckenzie we
communicated with players and agents
i'm not sure what the communication
level is up there
and i get it you know they manage they
pick players and players play
but aaron's been very candid like there
needs to be a little more tlc up there
and if that's not the way it goes it's
not the way it goes
but i have a feeling there are other
players that feel that way they just
can't say it because they don't have the
gravitas that aaron does but at the end
of the day
listen this is not new suzy and they've
been in the nfc championship the last
two years and i think they're well
positioned to get there again
so you know we can talk all about
what's going on off the field but on the
field they're pretty damn good
there was one moment that aaron rodgers
said
it's been all over the place green bay
is not a vacation destination they're
coming here
to play with me how do you think that's
going to play
for the locals in green bay
you know it really resonated with me you
know i was there 10 years
i had a tough time you know with
recruiting free agents
um and i think that's just reality
it's not the most diverse place and
you know i my story with charles woodson
every calling him
his agent every day for three months
even though i knew he had no other
options
you know it's tough and i
what do i sell you know what am i
selling
to a 25 year old i'm selling football
and i in those days i'm selling brett
favre
and in these days you're selling aaron
rodgers i get it
i get it in terms of how it plays i mean
what i told players and they found out
was that hey you get there it's kind of
like a college atmosphere that
place wraps itself around you like no
other sports team in the world and
it's great and they tend to find that
when they get there
but trying to convince someone i mean
listen
i'm from back east i lived in california
when i go to those places
yeah i'm sure they ask what everyone
asked which is
how do you live there i got asked that
the whole time so i get it
you know i think we have to be realistic
about this that
this is not a place it's geographically
undesirable to a lot of people
when aaron mentioned charles woodson
julius peppers he mentioned other guys
that had
left how realistic was that
well i don't think that's too out of the
norm
right listen this cold business you know
all my
writing and podcasts and talking is
about the business of sports
i don't think that's out of the realm
pick your favorite team
you know pick your team that team has
let a lot of veterans go
without a lot of fanfare without a lot
of tlc
they're on the waiver wire one day
they're on to the next
now you know i can understand what he's
saying about charles and peppers and
micah hyde and jordy nelson that was
in his words i don't know if he used the
word unceremonious but yeah
and what i think he's saying suzy is
guess who's next
guess who's next you know in march
he's next now there'll be a lot of
fanfare and he'll be a
packer hall of famer and like brett you
know he'll come back one day and
everybody will kiss and make up but
but he's next and think about that
he's the next one on that list and
that'll be in march
god can you think of a more stressful
nfl
situation this year than the green bay
packers
you know again i was there for the messy
divorce of brett
because we had seen this guy rogers
during the off seasons brett would go to
mississippi and aaron ran the team for
two seasons two off seasons
we felt comfortable turning the keys
over to this guy
they've seen jordan love really one off
season and he'll play the whole
august i don't think aaron will play in
the preseason
and i hope he looks good god i hope he
looks good
because yeah it's a succession plan
and i mean everyone said last year oh
aaron's gonna be so motivated because
they picked jordan and now they're
saying it again
but motivated or not i mean he's he's a
hall of fame talent
i think he's the best player in the
league i i
you know he'll do what he does he's got
good players around him
and one of the best receivers in the
league so stressful yeah
but i think aaron
is certainly able to compartmentalize
speaking of receivers devonte adams
wants to be the highest paid
player in the league at the wide
receiver position at the white out
position
and uh it sounded like brian guticune
said something like well there's
different ways to ascertain
the highest paid player
money's money andrew how do you
ascertain that
well i don't know if you you know you
can blame me for that because you used
to come in for salary cap lessons
i'd say you know things that well you
look at this
it's got more guaranteed this one has
more money up front this one has more
money in the first three years
so blame me for that but um
but yeah i mean the bottom line is he
will be they'll give him the money
i don't know if it's them somebody again
if aaron's going and he'll be afraid i
mean listen
i don't know who it's going to be but
if they make him the highest paid and
it's determined by him and his agent
that those categories i just mentioned
all match up
yeah you should take it
how do you think the season ends we just
look into your crystal ball what's your
prediction
listen there are a few plays away last
year from the super bowl
i know everybody loves you know the
bucks running it back
i know there are other contenders you
know i think stafford will make the rams
a lot better
um but i get you know i still have my
bias
i mean i think i need to say that you
know 10 years and i'm
i'm a real admirer of aaron for a lot of
reasons i would
for being with him for four years to
start with
so i think i think it ends with the
backers in aaron's
new hometown of la in the super bowl
his new hometown again people are going
to make a big deal of it but
again this is not drama this is not a
soap opera on tv
this he's he's he can compartmentalize
you know he's doing this they're good
he'll be somewhere else next year and i
think
they've got a real chance to to bro to
win this thing
before i let you go how close to
retirement do you think he really was
i never saw you retire you know um
the problem is you know and
i always said this all off season i said
he's not james harden
you know there's just a different level
of player empowerment in the nba
and maybe other sports then there's the
nfl life is about options and timing he
had no options really
the other option was retiring but i
can't see aaron rodgers sitting there
and not playing when the season's going
on i just can't see it with the drive
that he has
and more than the drive the talent you
know i think he's
you know you can argue my homes he's
still about the most talented kind of
league at that position his arm talent
is superior i saw it from day one
in 2005 and um
throwing it better than ever so i never
thought that was part of the equation
though
i just think he has to look at tom brady
in tampa bay and think why aren't they
listening to me
the way that team listens to him
i agree you know brady set off something
and i think in russell wilson too
we're like they're thinking huh why
can't i get some of that
but let's let's be real brady sat 20
years you know and this new brady we've
seen for two years especially social
media it's like he's been freed
and the patriots gave him the void
they gave him the void you know whatever
you want to say about the patriots being
hard asses on a negotiating table
they gave him the void they basically
put the runway for him to get out and he
got out
and he got personnel you know of course
if tampa is going to get them
they're going to give them things in
free agency and one of those things is a
lot of input
maybe erin will get that next year but
it's not going to be through a void
which i was surprised i thought maybe
he'd get the void and he didn't
but got the board in two years but i
think they'll trade him this year
and um but he's not getting that in
green bay and i think we all know that
andrew we know you're a man in demand
thank you so much for your time here on
the rich eisen show today
always enjoyed coming on with you guys
take care thanks so much
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here